hot breath this is the first one i'm
seeing here from lee hudson who is
actually
a um one of our comedians out in the uk
he said how do you know when a bit
is done
um that's a good question because i've
had bits i thought were done that
evolved
later you know sometimes i'll do the you
know when you do the bit and sometimes
an audience member will say something
and because they have a whole different
you know life experience and different
point of view they
they might comment on it or tag it and
you're like oh i didn't
how come i didn't think of that oh
right and you and
and you know i'll make a joke and say
thanks for thanks for that you know i'm
gonna
use that my hbo special you'd be in your
double by going hey that's my
joke um which is weird because the guy's
british
but um the so the joke
it usually a joke resolves huh right you
can feel the resolution of a joke it's
almost like a major scale
like a song it's like do re mi fa
solatito
right so dori mi faso la ti good night
everyone no i need the dough
the audience will sit there and go right
so if somebody else sees something
another play that didn't get resolved in
that you know another opportunity wait
what about that
you didn't resolve that part of it and
they might say that out loud you go oh
thanks
never thought about that so usually you
can hear resolve well you make your
point because
every joke should have you're coming
from somewhere what are you trying to
say with that joke
once you say it joke's done
boom i love it